the the in the developed world most
people because we haven't lived through
and through inflation or hyperinflation
have no idea that the dollar might not
be stable
and so when the dollar ultimately isn't
stable which notice I said said when not
if it is when when that happens then
it's going to be a a cold shower it's
going to be a big shock to a lot of
people and the same thing's true in in
much of the developed world
[Music]
oh
all right guys bang bang Caitlyn I
thought a great place to start this
conversation would just be what the hell
is going on what has happened with this
current banking crisis
uh well uh it's where do we start uh it
all traces back to the FED it all traces
back to Fed policy and uh and U.S
government policy during during covid uh
where almost five trillion dollars was
put onto the U.S commercial Banks
balance sheets and to give you a sense
there's 18 trillion of deposits right
now okay so that went up by a staggering
percentage just in the last three years
due to covet and what ended up happening
during covid is that nobody in the
private sector really except for large
corporations were borrowing so what
happened in the segment of the banks
that serve small and you know more more
more Rural and localized businesses
which is the heart the backbone of
America the answer is they weren't
borrowing and unless they were doing it
through PPP loans so what happened
here's the punch line is about five
trillion dollars of U.S treasuries got
purchased by the banking sector right
before
the big increase in interest rates that
started a year ago okay so to say that
this is the origin of this really is
Federal Reserve policy is 100 accurate
uh what I don't understand and I'm am
staggered by is how the bank Regulators
missed this they just I guess they just
took the assumption that even though the
the U.S treasuries on those community
and Regional Banks balance sheets were
marked to Market at huge losses due to
the increase in interest rates
that have happened over the last year
they just look the other way and assumed
that the world wouldn't figure out that
there's a solvency hole in the banking
system especially at the community and
Regional banks that has exploded into
the consciousness
right now because of social media
information you can't hide something
like that anymore everyone is now
understanding it and idea ironically it
was the citizen journalists who really
revealed it all and then the mainstream
media picked it up but the Staggering
speed with which we've seen these Bank
collapses you and I were watching
silvergate which is not a bank that most
of the world was watching but it wasn't
even a week after silvergate announced
that it was liquidating that Silicon
Valley Bank happened and by then the
entire VC world was on to this whole
Bank Run issue and telling all of their
portfolio companies get your cash out of
these small Banks and either put it in
U.S treasuries or put it into the large
Banks and so that's in a nutshell what
happened it in retrospect is obvious
that this was going to happen when you
realize that information travels at the
speed of light and that you we're not in
these old It's a Wonderful Life analog
type Bank runs anymore you can literally
move billions of dollars at the speed of
your phone from a remote location so I
saw Janet Yellen uh over the last couple
of days talk about the fact that they
never anticipated the speed at which
these Bank runs could happen and I think
she was specifically talking about these
kind of uh I called a digital
catastrophe right it's a negative event
that happens in the real world but it is
accelerated and caused by the speed of
information and action online
um phones have been around computers
have been around uh right is it just
like it had never happened before so
like it was hiding in plain sight was it
something where people just thought like
oh online banking isn't nearly as
popular as it actually became like what
was the disconnect between the
technology existing people using it but
actually them not preparing for it well
so this is where I can get into the fact
that the bank Regulators are oftentimes
engaged in group think okay and they
have an incredible level of detail in
the regulations and everyone naturally
assumes that the regulations are going
to prevent Bank runs and frankly in the
last decade the regulations have been so
strict that virtually no banks have
failed
um it's also true therefore that
virtually no innovation has happened in
the banking sector right capitalism of
course is creative destruction and so
when you have no banks failing that
tells you something but it's to use the
Nasim taleb analogy that if you don't
let a forest fire burn and burn the the
you know the the the dead stuff at the
bottom of the forest floor when it
finally Burns it turns into a
conflagration so that's that's
definitely happened here but I think the
bank Regulators just assumed that they
that there was not ever going to be a
bank run at the speed I mean you just
you just saw Yellen who's a former Fed
chair admit that
um The Challenge though is that I think
also part of what is going on here as
I've heard from insiders in DC is that
the bank Regulators wanted to take down
some of the more Tech forward Banks uh
because they were not necessarily
healing to the bank Regulators the way
that the bank Regulators who have
tremendous power have wanted them to and
and those banks are the banks that have
especially fast systems okay silvergate
signature and Silicon Valley Bank all
had apis both silvergate and signature
were operating 24 7 365.
ways just basically Ledger entries
within the bank so if you had two
customers within the bank who wanted to
move money to each other after banking
hours or on weekends they could do so at
the speed of light through those apis
those apis scared the bank regulators
and there was an incredible piece in the
Wall Street Journal yesterday which laid
out what happened at Silicon Valley Bank
the fed the Silicon Valley Bank tried to
get money through the FED through Bank
of New York and the window had closed
and that there wasn't an ability for the
FED to move the money that quickly at 4
pm okay this is not you know at 11 p.m
it's at 4 P.M and and the reason is
because it had to do a test trade okay
and the FED wouldn't wouldn't do the
test trade after hours and it turns out
that the money arrived the next morning
but by then uh the FDIC had already
closed the bank down that was on Friday
a week and a half ago
so here's the punch line the the systems
have not been updated and that scares
the bank regulator so what did they
systematically do they went out and
proverbially shot the most tech forward
Banks now stop and think about that
people are voting with their feet to use
better faster cheaper ways of moving
money and what did the bank Regulators
just do shut down some of the most tech
forward banks in the country who can
move money better faster and cheaper
that should scare every American because
and you saw it in the white house by the
way this has been all coordinated the
White House report that came out the day
before was dunking on financial
Innovation and talking about how we
should basically just stick with our
banks which are safe and sound that was
a hilarious observation because of
course we all know the banks are not
safe and sound it's now very clear that
there is a solvency Hole by the way
there always has been it's just that now
everybody's realizing it and so this so
the next point is that when the White
House is out there saying basically
taking an anti-in Innovation stance and
you see what the bank Regulators have
done to shut down some of the most tech
forward Banks they want to retrograde
technology back to the analog world and
it's fascinating as a political move
because there are more moderate people
in the Biden Administration and I've
been waiting for them to raise their
head there's a new person who hasn't
been announced yet who I know is a
cooler head and I hope that when that
person gets in their seat that uh that
that they're able to have a an impact
and and and walk some of this back
because you cannot stop the march of
technology and what will end up
happening is that if if The Regulators
are trying to force everything to slow
down and to go back to the analog world
where you have to go into a bank branch
to be able to move your money then uh
people that will accelerate the move to
to crypto and and other payment rails
that are outside of the system they're
going to get at what they actually fear
which which actually happens so often
when people make decisions on the basis
of fear you get what you feared so part
of this insolvency issue is this like
held to maturity
um you know some people call it an
accounting trick some people will say no
it makes sense can you unpack your view
as to taking these assets putting them
in a certain part of the balance sheet
and basically saying hey we can just
evaluate these at par not marking them
to Market and why that's become such a
big issue now
well that was a way for the The
Regulators to basically it is an
accounting trick uh because The
Regulators could look at that and say
well the bank is solvent because they
haven't marked these unrealized losses I
would I I I like to point to Tom honig
the former president of the Kansas City
fed who correctly points out that the
the risk-based capital approach of the
banking sector there's this gets into a
little bit inside baseball but here's
here's the plain English version of it
the capital regime missed something big
which is that U.S treasuries attracted
no risk weight
so what did the banks do when this five
trillion dollars of extra deposit
suddenly shows up again from 13-ish
trillion to 18 trillion in three years
there's there's this huge deposit in
flux and what did they do they bought
the risk-free asset that didn't require
because they hadn't raised additional
Capital so they bought the risk-free
asset they all reached for yield and got
greedy though and that's where they took
on the interest rate risk and the
capital models for the smaller Banks did
not reflect the capital charge for that
interest rate risk and so the banks are
all going to point fingers at the bank
Regulators which is why by the way you
have seen this is incredible you have
seen a number of people on both sides of
the political aisle and in places like
the Washington Post of all places really
criticizing the fed and the FDIC to a
lesser degree the OCC these you these
were Untouchables before these agencies
and now they're getting incredible
criticism
that is a sea change folks the FED has
historically been able to sort of stay
above The Fray not anymore boy oh boy
have we seen direct criticism coming
from both sides of the political aisle
of the of the bank Regulators for having
missed all this and it was because the
capital model didn't apply to the small
and medium-sized banks that picked up
the capital that should have been
required from the interest rate risk and
here's what Tom honig pointed out it
might have looked like these Banks were
well capitalized because of that
accounting trick but if you really Mark
to market the losses they were they were
very thinly capitalized and and if not
insolvent
when we try to unpack who's responsible
for this is it the fed and the interest
rates you know kind of hiking and kind
of going against the guidance they had
given is it the FDIC or the OCC who
maybe didn't oversee this as much is
there maybe blame to be put on the
actual management teams of the banks who
didn't have good risk management is it
all of them like how do you kind of you
know pin the tail on the donkey and say
okay here is who is at fault for this
it's it's all of them and the Paul
politicians too was the other group that
you missed right for overreacting and
you know basically just throwing all
this all this debt onto the US economy
when people were literally sitting at
home watching Netflix and you know
gambling with their stemi checks okay so
that's part of it too uh but yeah I mean
at the end of the day the management
teams did not have to accept the extra
deposits they did not and they did not
have to take those deposits and
roll the dice with them by investing in
long-term assets okay
silvergate had a huge influx of deposits
and the numbers that I have off the top
of my head because I looked at this
right before the crypto bankruptcy
started in Q2 2022 silvergate had 13.3
billion of deposits that could be
withdrawn within the span of minutes
and it had 1.4 billion of cash 13.3
billion
of deposits that could go poof and 1.4
billion of cash it's not rocket science
what happened there it's not but what
what what we are now seeing is that that
same issue could happen at any of these
banks that have these big unrealized
losses and are not sitting on cash very
very interesting editorial in the
Washington Post again this morning
they've been very critical of these Bank
bank Regulators which have historically
been Teflon and they're not now in the
Washington Post editorial page this
morning they they came out and said that
FDIC should not guarantee all Bank
deposits but they did call for
guaranteeing the the deposits for
payroll okay and there was a really
interesting Harvard Business review the
article that came out on Friday that
said we need safe Banks okay we because
you know if anybody's got more than say
15 or 20 employees their payroll that
they pay is probably more than 250 000
okay and so there's there's literally no
reason why businesses who are paying
payroll should have to take counterparty
credit exposure to their Bank the bank
should be sitting on cash for those
payments and that is exactly what these
non-blending Bank Charters were proposed
to be and you've seen that the FED
blocked them and again I you know my own
bank custodia with whom you're familiar
um six weeks before the bank runs the
FED blocked custodia's business model
which was exactly that a payment bank
that was sitting 100 in cash and now
we're seeing calls from all kinds of
mainstream places for exactly that
so the idea of a safe bank right I've
been Googling around and there ain't
that many of them that claim to be
actually safe in terms of not following
the fractional Reserve System the word
safe the word uh kind of deposits all
these things now are bubbling up and the
average American is kind of looking for
where is the safe bank I think that we
can split this conversation into two
pieces there's the big Banks versus the
regional Banks and then there is
fractional Reserve banking versus
non-fractional Reserve banking uh I'm an
investor in custodia obviously you know
kind of the pitch and approach that you
guys have taken uh is something that I
think is needed in the banking system
explain fractional Reserve versus
non-fractional reserve and why that
potentially could be this safe bank that
everyone is seeking
okay so fractional Reserve banking when
you put your deposit into a bank the
bank turns around and lends it out it's
a classic borrow short term and invest
long term so the banks are investing in
loans or they're buying Securities like
we just talked about so they're taking
it's it's the Silver Gate numbers I just
said that that they're taking in demand
deposits that could literally go poof
and turning around and investing a
hundred percent
um in in in in long-term assets okay and
in silvergate's case they had 1.4
billion of cash on against 13.3 billion
of demand deposits but I've seen an
analysis of all the publicly traded
Banks only a handful of them have enough
cash and available for sale Securities
to meet demand deposits okay that's the
way Financial fractional Reserve banking
works the banks are just not sitting on
cash they're they're basically you know
it's it's the best analogy is if you
parked your car at a valet parking
garage while you were having dinner
and the valet garage rented out your car
to an Uber driver and pocketed all the
money and you didn't know you had risk
because that car was out being you know
driven around and heaven forbid if the
Uber driver crashed your car guess what
you have an unexpected Financial loss
and you would feel pretty angry
but that's exactly how banking works and
and that's the fractional Reserve model
uh there's there the banks are taking
risk with your money and not sharing the
rewards with you and not being
transparent about it the challenge in
the United States is that that is
exactly legal and that is how the
banking sector has the banking system
has worked for decades it's it but you
can see how it's fundamentally unstable
when the when you deposit your money at
a bank and the bank turns around and
lends your money while you think your
money is there the whole business model
rests upon the confidence that not
everybody will go and withdraw at the
same time and when we see a bank run
happening where everybody goes and
withdrawals at the same time the
insolvency that was always there becomes
revealed
when we then look at the big Banks
versus the regional Banks it seems like
the regional banks have been exposed
more and I don't know if that's like a
psychological and confidence thing where
people are saying oh this small Bank
probably has less assets it probably
isn't as big as the JP Morgan's uh and
others or is there something that is
structurally different in the regulation
their Capital uh balances what what is
the difference here it's the latter
because the latter are subject to the
Basel III requirements where they have
something called a liquidity coverage
ratio and they're required to sit on
liquid assets to to pay off their
volatile deposits that could be
withdrawn in a short period of time so
the regional and Community Banks have
not been subject to those same
requirements and that's exactly the
issue that we're seeing that's why you
see a lot of people are saying this
particular issue is a U.S specific issue
because in most other countries there
are only a handful of Banks and um and
they're all subject to the Basel III
requirements and therefore they're
required to sit on more liquidity so the
impact of this is that this is one of
the reasons why a lot of people have
been predicting and indeed we've seen
her I just was looking at it at a JP
Morgan report this morning since this
banking Crisis began 1.1 trillion
dollars of deposits have migrated from
Community Banks and again total the
total is is just under 18 trillion
um so this is not small okay big big
money movement happening right now 1.1
trillion of deposits have been have
migrated out and where are they going
they're mostly going into into T bills
into the U.S treasury market
um but so yes there is something
specific about the small and um and
medium-sized banks in this country
because they weren't required to sit on
all that liquidity and everyone just you
know kind of sprayed and prayed that
that the that all the depositors didn't
show up at the same time but in an era
of the internet where information moves
at the speed of light a bank run
obviously can happen like that the
liquidity requirements that Regulators
have have had is is to assume that 35 of
the demand deposits disappear appear in
a run so when you're doing your stress
testing that's typically what happens
that's typically what The Regulators
will focus on but what we've seen is
that essentially a hundred percent of
those deposits not 35 percent could
disappear you know in trade 25 of the
deposits at Silicon Valley Bank
disappeared within hours so so I want to
separate out uh the idea of a bank run I
think most people whether it is the
analog world like go stand in a line and
wait for your money or kind of this
digital catastrophe hey I just open a
new tab I click some buttons and I move
my money that is one component of a bank
run and I think that is the acute like
uh 42 billion flows out of Silicon
Valley Bank in hours right there's a
second version of a bank run that is
occurring it is very slow and it is very
stealth but this Bank Run is essentially
this move from deposits into treasuries
and a lot of this again has to do with
the interest rate where if the interest
rates continue to increase then
naturally I can earn more yield on my
assets so I go and I buy treasuries
rather than leave it and get paid my
0.03 percent or whatever the bank is
offering me right and so talk a little
bit as to like what stress is that
putting on the system as well
well it's putting enormous stress right
because the the reason why that your
your small and Regional banks have not
paid interest on that even remotely
Rises to the level of what you can earn
in t-bills is because they know their
Capital constraint and so they're trying
to pocket that spread to rebuild their
their solvency and so unfortunately now
that the world has figured out that
there's a solvency problem in in as a
whole in some in in whole segments of
the banking industry when you mark to
Market those assets then what does it
mean it means that the assets migrate
into T bills or it migrates into the
large Banks and we've seen we've seen a
degree of both the cat that the movement
has come out of the small and Regional
Bank small and medium-sized Banks into
the large Banks and then there's money
moving from the large Banks into T bills
and a lot of people don't don't think
the large Banks could be in trouble but
here's one of the challenges is the US
government fiscal policy is is requiring
the issuance of Staggering amounts of
treasuries that's how the US government
finances itself it's through something
called the primary dealers all of the
large Banks for the most part are
primary dealers what is it what does
that mean it means the banks have to buy
the treasuries that the U.S treasury is
auctioning off they they bid for them at
market prices and they turn around and
resell them at some sort of a spread
that's the business model but there's
going to come a time when when we're not
going to be able to to sell additional
treasury debt and the impact of that is
that the is that these large banks are
going to get stuck with treasuries that
can't be sold okay so I am looking ahead
and thinking you know all this money
that's going in this flight to safety
into the very large Banks I'm not so
sure that that's so reliable either so
everybody just you know do your homework
and start thinking about what's going to
happen two or three steps down the road
in the future
um and and you know but it's always
going to it was always going to be that
if the U.S had a failed treasury auction
that that turns into a huge problem and
and I just walk you through one of the
mechanisms where that could happen at
some point in the future we don't know
if or when it will so I'm going to use
the government as a kind of overarching
term for the FED uh FDIC treasury
Etc they are bringing out a bazooka in
the sense of backstopping these Banks
and some of it is direct where they are
saying explicitly here is you know 100
billion dollars there's a 300 billion
dollar increase to the fed's balance
sheet uh there's all sorts of lending
programs that are propping up we also
see internationally the Swiss National
Bank stepping in and helping Credit
Suisse but then there is uh kind of this
indirect language that's being used that
like your deposits are safe and so all
of the assets all that Firepower that
they're throwing towards the banks
um I think it begs two different
questions one what happens to the dollar
and inflation and then the second is buy
proxy or we actually all just creating
bank accounts with the government and
naturally you we could erase the banks
and just like have fed based bank
accounts or is that pushing us towards
this like surveillance world that we
don't actually want to go down okay two
questions there let me answer the first
one really simply watch what they do not
what they say okay to your point they
have fired a bazooka they are so much
money being thrown at this problem to
try to restore confidence
um and and they're telling everybody
your deposits are safe but what they're
actually doing indicates that they are
panicking now to you to your next
question this is the Crux of the matter
there are some who think that the whole
tear it down so you can build it back
better is that there might be some
purpose to what has happened here I
don't have any evidence of that and I'm
not advocating for that but in that
scenario
the the notion that the banking system
was that unstable in the first place
does lend to lend some credibility to
the people who are worried that that
might actually be the case and and
essentially that the government steps in
and rescues the entire banking sector
now
um who if that were to happen who gets
the blame is really important you and I
know the banking sector is not a free
market animal never has been and since
hasn't been for for more than the last
century okay we had free market banks
that actually did fail and there was a
lot of Fraud and there were a lot of
problems there were a lot of Bank runs
during the Wildcat Bank banking era in
the in the in in the mid to late 1800s
okay but that also that these private
banks that had no government backstop no
FDIC insurance no Federal Reserve
because neither one of them existed at
that point and the banks were were
chartered by the states yes there were a
lot of problems but here's the punch
line
that banking system that was truly free
market
funded the greatest increase in the
middle class literally in any part of
human history okay through through
funding the industrialization of America
so despite all the problems there were
absolutely huge benefits to having a
true free market banking system and then
what happened is in 1913 the Fed was
created in 1933 the FDIC was created and
all of a sudden you had government
backstops and then what ended up
happening the the banks moved away from
their simple model that they had in the
in the 1800s of being money warehouses
remember back then money was gold and so
you would literally put your gold coins
into your bank and they would store them
as a in a vault as a money Warehouse
they moved away once they had a
government backstop from that
far less risky model towards the more
risky model of well let me take in
customer deposits turn around and lend
them right out and pray that not all of
the customers show up at the same time
and they got away with that because it
was not an Information Age
um and and of course some didn't get
away with that because some were some
were outright fraud and some were
massively leveraged and and blew up but
the the most honest Banks back then uh
their warehouse receipts traded as money
equivalents because people had a
knowledge and understanding and
confidence that those Banks really did
have the reserves in the form of gold
coins to cash people out if everybody
showed up at the same time so you had
Market forces that worked now since then
of course the government has stepped in
and it's encouraged these privatization
of profit socialization of losses type
business models where where the banks
are borrowing short-term and lending
long-term and basically uh you know the
bankers are on the golf course by three
is the proverbial proverbial uh you know
joke about the banking industry because
it's it's uh it's it is essentially a a
risk-free business where the government
will step in and guarantee deposits but
again I think the world is changing look
at the look at the mainstream media
calling for safe Banks and look at look
at the Washington Post calling for don't
if we're not guaranteeing all Bank
deposits this whole idea of a put back
to the government There's real pushback
coming from places you wouldn't expect
this time around
when we see them stepping in as they
have done now for a very long time uh
the idea that they take more risk
because they know there's a backstop in
the banks uh take more risk that seems
to make sense uh but now that they are
stepping in with that bazooka there are
folks like abalaji srinivasan many other
folks who would believe that all of this
kind of monetary stimulus all of this uh
backing of the banks is going to lead to
higher inflation on the low end or
potentially hyper inflation on the kind
of most extreme end do you subscribe to
that thought process do you think that
there's critiques there that maybe
they're missing how do you look at it
yeah so that's very good question and
you asked it before I didn't get back to
to that
um here's the thing the debt gets
created in different places okay and so
when the debt gets monetized by the FED
what they're trying to do is keep the
system inflated keep keep the the total
amount of debt in the non-financial
sector growing and I looked it up the
FED has data in something called the Z1
you can go find this yourselves
non-financial sector total liabilities
were 70 trillion at the end of 2017 the
94 trillion at the end of 2022. okay in
just five years it went from 70 to 94
trillion okay that's that that is the
biggest acceleration of debt of all time
now now we started to get inflation due
to supply chain issues and the FED is
trying to reduce demand in order to
bring inflation down for something that
is fundamentally a supply chain problem
so if I were the FED right now I would
be screaming at Congress deregulate
deregulate let's get these Supply chains
back up and running and instead what's
happening is due to the geopolitical
situation and due to sanctions and due
to
um you know relations between nations
trade has has has has
been clipped in its wings and you're now
starting this is part of the reason that
you that this is a supply sign issue not
a demand side issue but the FED is
trying to deal with it by reducing
demand and you're seeing that it's not
having that big of an impact and instead
what it's what it's doing is is is
causing real problems in the banking
industry so the punch line is I don't
think this is the big one yet so to
speak uh and biology obviously does
think it is the big one he might be
right because when you look at the
instability of the banking system you
look at it and say how can this thing
possibly go on but what those of us who
have been watching it for years have
recognized is none of this is new folks
and so what he's basically saying is a
lot of folks are waking up and realizing
that this is the case even though it's
been the case all along it's really the
end of the confidence in the system is
what he's calling for and I don't think
we're there yet I really don't but
um to your to answer your question
directly I do think we're going to have
hot inflation because the government has
decided that they have to save the
banking system especially the fed the
FED will always step in and save the
banking system folks that was what it
was created for go back and read
um the creature from Jekyll Island and
you'll see that that was a historian
written book about the corrupt bargain
that created the FED in the first place
it was six bankers and a U.S senator and
an assistant U.S treasury secretary that
got together under the guise of a
hunting trip to figure out after the
Panic of 1907 how the banking system
could basically have a taxpayer backstop
and that's exactly what we've had Ergo
we have not had free markets in banking
since then and um and and this is this
is how we get all these bailouts uh but
but you're seeing calls from both the
left and the right in this country
saying enough we can't keep doing this
because it is privatized profits and
socialized losses and it is angering
people and it is here's the punch line
on inflation it is going to keep
inflation running hot because they can't
raise interest rates high enough without
bankrupting the the banking sector so
there seems to be this trade-off save
the banks save the dollar I don't know
if that's just hyperbole or that is
actually kind of the trade-off but if
they are guaranteed to step in and save
the banks and they're going to have to
do it with these kind of monetary
Bazookas then the dollar will likely run
hot which you know I agree in terms of
the the inflation the question becomes
how severe is that move right and
hyperinflation kind of being you know 50
year-over-year inflation uh we got up to
nine percent but we were 20 of the way
there which again nine percent is very
different than 50 obviously but also I
think that people have already kind of
forgotten that we were at nine percent
and if they had not stepped in and
raised interest rates and conducted
quantitative tightening who knows where
we would have gone and so is your
thought process that when we talk about
inflation running hot like 10 12 do you
think it's like a 20 could it go higher
like understand you can't predict the
future but like what is the severity of
what your expectation is at least given
the information we have today yeah I I
I'm not an economist who makes economic
forecasts but it's definitely going to
continue to be above the two percent
level shall we say I mean at some point
the FED is going to have to acknowledge
that that its Target of two percent is
not going to be reasonable for it to
reach any time in the next
um probably decade given given the
situation where we are right now and
given the debt levels
um so so that's the punch line that
that's my guess but I don't I
acknowledge biology could be right and
um and this all could come crashing down
tomorrow I don't think it will uh and if
it does boy you know I don't want to
live in that world part of what you and
I are working towards is moving towards
a more stable Financial system so we
don't have the risk of that sort of
Damocles hanging over our heads it has
been hanging over our heads all along
and most people just have been
blissfully ignorant of it I kind of want
I kind of wish I were as well but it's
funny I've been watching it and you've
talked about this you talked about this
with all of you you asked him how many
mainstream traditional Finance people
have woken up to the insolvency of the
system and are looking for ways out
including buying Bitcoin and he said a
lot and I have experienced the same
thing and I'm seeing a lot of people
waking up from the traditional Finance
industry just like I did in 2008 saying
something's wrong this is fundamentally
unstable something's wrong I'm gonna go
get curious and dig in and when they dig
in they're going to get orange filled
into Bitcoin in most cases because
they're going to realize that there is a
fundamentally more stable system out
there right now bitcoin's price is
incredibly volatile but as a system it's
it's it's sound because there's no debt
in the system that because Bitcoin is no
one's IOU it is if you own the on-chain
Bitcoin it is not issued by anyone it is
something that that organically arose
between people and there's no issuer
unlike fiat currency where there's an
issuer every dollar is actually an IOU
go look at the at the piece of paper in
your wallet if you still carry physical
cash it says it's an IOU it's paid to
the order of from the Federal Reserve
Bank it is an IOU and what's backing
that IOU it's Turtles all the way down
so to speak it's just the full faith and
credit of the US government well what
does that mean is that anything more
than a Confidence Game other is that
more than than the confidence game that
that Bitcoin or gold or real estate are
everything is subjective the whole
concept of money is ephemeral and and
once you get your hands around that then
you realize wow I would rather store the
fruits of my labor in an honest Ledger
that no one can manipulate and you
pretty quickly come to hard assets like
Bitcoin as being something that you want
to have in your portfolio and then you
start to realize wow I can move Bitcoin
better faster cheaper as a payment
system especially using a layer two like
lightning Network then you're in a whole
different Paradigm than the traditional
banking system and again I cannot
underscore just how important it is that
the bank Regulators moves against these
Tech forward Banks and the White House
coming out and criticizing Financial
Innovation they are trying to retrograde
regress the the technology of the U.S
financial system because they're afraid
of it and it's just like the taxi and
limousine commissions with Uber they're
going to get overrun and I really wish
they they that cooler heads would
prevail so we spent a lot of time
talking about the United States economy
the U.S banking system but there's many
places around the world where people
have no confidence in their National
currency they have no confidence in
their banking system
Etc are there lessons to learn from some
of those International markets that
either the U.S uh kind of current regime
could learn from to prevent this from
happening or individuals could study and
say hey let me take those lessons away
so that I'm prepared in case something
catastrophic does happen I'm so glad you
asked that question because we tend to
be so america-centric and and
non-americans who have had Direct
experience with this absolutely get
Bitcoin off the top of their heads
because they've they've lived in many
cases with with inflation or
hyperinflation in some cases during our
lifetimes and so they intuitively get
the idea of a non-government money that
a dictator or an authoritarian
government cannot manipulate period and
and so yes um if you look at the price
reaction in Bitcoin it still is trading
as a risk-on asset but but the
correlation with Equity markets is
breaking and I think that that is that
is an interesting sign is this a
short-term thing or is this a long-term
thing we don't know and I I tend to
think that the price of Bitcoin is the
is the least interesting aspect of
Bitcoin as you know and I don't trade it
myself uh but it it is um it is the
price action is telling the regulator
something and it is global and I think
you know to the extent that we've got
some Trad five people who are getting
orange pill then starting to buy it
that's helping push the price up but
most importantly it's these offshore
folks who have a direct experience with
this that in the developed world most
people because we haven't lived through
and through inflation or hyperinflation
have no idea that the dollar might not
be stable
and so when the dollar ultimately isn't
stable which notice I said said when not
if it is when when that happens then
it's going to be a a cold shower it's
going to be a big shock to a lot of
people and the same thing's true in in
much of the developed world the last
thing I want to talk about in terms of
the dollar-based system uh currently is
this geopolitical risk uh it's kind of
how I characterize it so obviously when
Russia invaded Ukraine the United States
NATO and other allies around the world
put a sledgehammer in terms of financial
sanctions both on uh the government of
Russia but also private citizens they uh
literally confiscated assets and kind of
did things that we had never really seen
a country do before I've had individuals
on uh literally from you know the
economics Department of Harvard all the
way down to your average uh Bitcoin pleb
who have talked about uh wait a minute
there are countries that are going to
wake up to the fact that now there needs
to be assets that you own have
sovereignty and custody of that could be
a sanctions hedge uh we also recently
have seen both president XI from China
and Vladimir Putin from Russia getting
together having all sorts of
conversations that seem very friendly uh
and a proposal of like this like brics
type currency regime how do you just
evaluate geopolitical risk and like the
US Dollars role in all this well it's
all part of the dedolarization that has
been happening and the weaponization of
the U.S financial system that has been
happening ironically a lot of people
look at this being as more of a Democrat
thing I look at it as more of a
republican thing it's the neocons which
exist in both political parties that
want to weaponize the US dollar system
and the impact of that is to push people
out of it that that may come crosswise
and your your point is well taken that
that the U.S chucked out the rule of law
there were there were a lot of people
who may not have been associated with
regimes who got caught up
in those sanctions and if you go back to
we've by the way but by the way this is
also not new if you go back to the 1950s
when the Cold War Began between the US
and Russia the the the the OPEC the deal
that was cut with OPEC was that OPEC
would only sell oil in dollars okay
Russia is an oil Rich nation and so it
was getting all these dollars but the
U.S banks wouldn't Bank them
sounds familiar right what did they do
the British Bank said well we'll Bank
you will open up US dollar accounts and
we'll create an offshore Market that is
not within the direct reach of U.S Bank
regulators and lo and behold this
offshore Market which is which which is
confusingly called the euro dollar
market just means US Dollars transacting
offshore that offshore Market is
actually bigger than the onshore US
dollar market and so
um that that has ultimately been where
where a lot of the activity has gone and
it was because the Russian basically a
U.S policy pushed the Russian Banks into
the hands of the British Bank the
Russian oil producers into the hands of
the British banks in the 1950s and then
ultimately it just exploded and now it
turned into these the you know global
trade and Global banks that have U.S
dollar exposures interestingly Credit
Suisse the failure credit Suites over
the weekend is it is an interesting case
because 20 years ago I worked in Zurich
reporting directly to the co-ceos of
credit
in one of the other times when Credit
Suisse almost went bust and the stock
had gone from 90 to 19 it was the
insurance subsidiary that imploded and I
got helicoptered in as part of a team to
go work on the restructuring of the
insurance subsidiary and I was in touch
with the team that was working on the
restructuring of the parent company as
well I was reporting directly to John
Mack and Aussie group all these are you
know very very no well-known and
respected names in banking and that team
I remember distinctly a conversation
that Credit Suisse was so big relative
to Switzerland if you looked at credit
Suites and UBS back then so big relative
to the Swiss economy that if either one
of them went down
that it would become the fed's problem
and what have we seen that's exactly
what we just saw right so so UBS was
forced into
rescuing Credit Suisse and I'm very glad
that Colin Kelleher the guy who uh who
hired me into Morgan Stanley in 2007
he's now the executive chairman of UBS
the executive chairman is really in the
Swiss structure or the CEO as we would
think about it in the American structure
in other words the guy in charge
um and he said this was an emergency
rescue make no make no mistake about it
he's absolutely right and I'm glad he
said that out loud but the impact of
that is if you look at what the bank
Regulators did again they panicked you
saw the the what's called swap lines
open up among five of the global central
banks now they had been open since the
2008 financial crisis you go back to the
2008 financial crisis most of the
increase in the fed's balance sheet from
800 billion to 3 trillion back then went
to foreign Banks but if they had
actually said that this was a rescue of
the offshore Banks then there would have
been enormous political blowback back
then okay and so it's happening again
though folks and I don't think that that
that because again we're in the internet
era I don't think they're going to be
able to keep the lid on it this time
that the bulk of well we'll see the
fed's balance sheet is is they disclose
our balance sheet on a weekly basis and
we'll see what those swap line usage
numbers are but I have a feeling they're
going to be very large and uh when the
Swiss National Bank gave a 100 billion
dollar backstop to Credit Suisse well
really to UBS to to to to create
liquidity for credits for for the uh
Credit Suisse acquisition look at the
GDP of Switzerland folks you know it
just dwarves the GDP of Switzerland
where did that money come from it came
from the ECB and most especially from
the Fed
so we're gonna see that play out in the
next few weeks so during all of these
banking crisis one other thing that's
been happening uh that I find
fascinating and somewhat concerning uh
to a degree as well is there's Equity
holders there's bondholders and there's
depositors and so when people talk about
a quote-unquote bailout what we have
seen so far has been a bailout of the
deposit or protection of the depositor
uh we have seen in most cases equity and
bondholders lose if there's a Bad Bet
yes they're losing as well they should
Yes except in the Credit Suisse
situation it appears that the
bondholders which normally would be able
to recoup their investment or or kind of
have first in line in terms of the
waterfall uh they actually got skipped
over for the equity investors and about
17 billion dollars of bonds got wiped
now I asked a friend what his view of
this was and he gave me a grin and he
said that's the European waterfall uh
but how do you how do you look at uh the
bondholders and the equity holders and
the treatment you know both here in the
US but also in this situation in Europe
yeah well that is an interesting
situation because the rule of law got
chucked out the window again right you
know in emergencies the rule of law
seems to disappear and in in in these
countries where the rule of law is
supposed to be reliable and Switzerland
is of course one of those
um when you see them chucked out for you
know emergencies you you should get
curious and dig in and figure out what
really happened here's what I think
really happened ubs's Equity value it
was only 46 ish billion okay and the
bondholders of Credit Suisse were 17 to
your point if they had made the
bondholders whole then you the control
of UBS would have transferred to the
bondholders of Credit Suisse
so I I suspect that what was how I don't
know this but I'm just looking at the
math like this is a huge number 17
billion when ubs's Equity was only 46.
okay and so ultimately by wiping them
out UBS kept control of its own company
it was probably one of the deals that
got cut in order for UBS to agree to be
forced into this now the other thing
that they did was change Swiss law again
rule of law gets chucked out the window
change Swiss law so that neither neither
side shareholders got to vote on this
um this kind of stuff boy it's it just
goes to show you that when you have this
kind of instability
it feeds into the more authoritarian
instincts of of both political parties
right where we have to Chuck out the
rule of law to save ourselves right
um and those kinds of things ultimately
do come back to to haunt the the the
governments and the people who who rely
on them there was a famous Thomas
Jefferson quote those those who would
give up Liberty for some temporary
safety deserve neither Liberty nor
safety and I think that's right
let's talk about choke point 2.0 and I
think this is a name that uh kind of the
internet has given a a series of events
um it doesn't seem that there has been
kind of official confirmation I don't
think anyone's expecting official
confirmation of this type of effort uh
but really choke point 2.0 uh it
references a Obama era program that used
the banking system as a way to
essentially Implement political views or
or kind of uh legislation without
actually having to go through the
legislative process
um and I would say that the the people
who were Pro choke point you know 1.0 uh
they said oh look the banks are able to
do whatever they want so what they got
pressured but like they're free actors
in The Market they decided to make these
decisions again that is their argument I
think the critiques of choke point 1.0
would be uh hey you basically are going
after law-abiding businesses and you are
not using the legislative and Democratic
process you're basically weaponizing the
banks and doing so via threats versus
that Democratic process it seems like
that's what we're seeing again here and
there's coordination or maybe it is just
great Serendipity which would be very
hard to wrap your headers okay so
explain kind of how you viewed choke
point 2.0 what's happening and like what
you think the ramifications are well let
me start with some evidence of the
coordination
um we didn't talk about this when it
happened but we've now shared it with
the people who need to know
we have we have a Smoking Gun we have it
in email from a reporter who was told
that the fed and OCC
upants for Bank Charters were asked
simultaneously to withdraw their
applications or they would be voted down
and custodia did not withdraw our
applications and uh the OCC you've seen
what's happened to the the pending OCC
applicants
um okay so that was the tip of the
spirit custodia was the tip of the spear
we have that evidence and we have more
than just that but that is the Smoking
Gun that proves there was coordination
both of both of those agencies are
supposed to be independent they are
required to abide by due process
requirements in the Constitution and in
the administrative procedure act and by
the agencies coordinating and by the way
we do know it was coordinated with the
white house as well again now that now
that six weeks have passed and you've
seen the magnitude of the coordination
uh it's pretty obvious that that it was
coordinated but back then there were a
lot of people saying prove it prove it
prove it well we had the proof we just
weren't in a position to talk about it
publicly and what happened is that two
days before custodia's application was
voted down by the Board of Governors we
were getting Halls because they had
leaked to the Press
that we're that our application was
about to be voted down and thank
goodness we didn't respond because then
one of the reporters put it in email
okay I'm I'm gonna defend the the
identity of the reporter the report the
reporter was just doing their job but
multiple reporters were involved in this
okay so they know and by the way we were
able to confirm it was both the White
House effectively and um effectively
confirmed it was both the White House
and the fed and one of the reasons we
knew it was the FED is because within
hours of us sending a letter to the
general counsel of the FED a reporter
was recounting it back to our PR officer
okay where's the due process in that now
what happened with custodia on the 27th
of January is the White House released
simultaneously with a Fed
anti-crypto policies at the same time as
they announced that custodia's
application had been withdrawn that was
all at 11 30 a.m Eastern on January 27th
or not withdrawn AB denied all of all
three coordinated to release the press
releases in the Big Bang and then with
precision timing hours later
the Kansas City fed denied our master
account application and then both
parties moved to dismiss our pending
lawsuit all that happened with precision
timing that day but here pump here's an
interesting aspect a lot of folks didn't
realize that was fomc blackout week the
FED never does anything during fomc
blackout week
and all of a sudden there's this vote
that happens on this very very very very
very very rushed timeline
during fomc blackout week what was going
on at the time in the fog of War we
didn't realize it it was all just this
coordinated start of operation choke
point 2.0 since then it has been and by
the way insiders have come in the
Washington is a sieve we've we've been
told exactly what happened and who it
was
um and by the way then Senator Dick
Durbin came over the top and attacked
custodia we're not even like we're not
even an operating bank yet how is it
that we had we were even on the White
House's radar screen and Senator Dick
Durbin's radar screen this was all this
very coordinated effort by the Biden
Administration to push crypto into the
shadows and now it's clear crystal clear
we've seen it with all of the actions
against paxos with the actions against
the stable coin producers uh um issuers
with the actions against Kraken between
the IRS and the SEC
most of the crypto exchanges got Wells
notices in early February
um and then you saw the SEC change the
custody rule proposed uh to change the
custody rule and then lastly yesterday
last night coinbase announced that it
had gotten a Wells notice they have
blanketed the entire industry with
enforcement actions and and um again the
White House said the quiet part out loud
and it's in its uh
in the in the economic report to the
president essentially dunking on all
Financial Innovation especially crypto
they want to bring us back to the 19th
century and I am floored by that again
I'm not making a political statement I
reject the politicization of what has
happened here
what I what I'm floored by is that the
cooler heads the more moderate Democrats
in the Biden Administration have been
steamrolled by the the anti-crypto
anti-tech group uh and what's really
going on here I don't know there are a
lot of people who think that it's you
know tear it down to build back better
so so that the government ends up with
more control and more surveillance and
that this is all a precursor to a
central bank digital currency I don't
have any evidence of that is it
plausible yes but I don't have any
evidence of that however I will say for
the first time a cbdc a retail cbdc
where everyone is every individual has a
has a bank account at the FED that is a
hill I will die on
when you see the destruction that is
happening first right kind of this like
blocking the exits if you will
um
is there a path to
Bitcoin cryptocurrencies this entire
industry uh kind of threading the needle
and finding a way to continue to thrive
or do you think it is catastrophic it is
this big external risk and It ultimately
will stop the growth of the industry
oh it's not going to stop the growth of
the industry because of what you just
talked about activists not it's
a curve is happening in places like El
Salvador and Nigeria and Zimbabwe right
um so it's not a U.S thing and and
um you know the industry is going to
just keep on ticking it is stunning to
me that as the U.S is closing off this
new technology China is opening it up
again we have Hong Kong now with the
approval of the of the Sea of the
Communist Party in China starting to
recruit Bitcoin businesses to come over
as they're being kicked out of the U.S
and the Middle East my gosh what's
happening in the Middle East is is very
positive so it's and Europe is embracing
it with of course European style
regulation but embracing it so it's the
U.S that's that that is the real outlier
here
um so I I have absolute confidence that
this is going to continue the question
is will Americans be able to participate
or are we all going to be forced
offshore uh and one of the interesting
things uh that that
um that you see right now is you know
coinbase has has decided to build an
offshore exchange they're essentially
acknowledging because of the hostility
of the U.S regulatory
regime that that you know they might
need to come up might might need to move
offshore you just saw crack and lose
um it's ACH access the debanking that's
happening in this industry is is is
staggering
as we start to see debanking choke point
2.0 there is Signature Bank which I
think is the big one that everyone's
pointing to what do you think happens
there Barney Frank who's the board
member he said hey look I think that the
bank wasn't insolvent uh obviously the
FDIC the FED others thought it was how
do you think this plays out and you
mentioned fog of War
does some of this just get lost and even
if things were done incorrectly or on
accelerated timelines or kind of as you
said the rule of log kind of gets thrown
out of uh during an emergency situation
like that ends up just being forgotten
in hindsight
oh it's not going to be forgotten that's
going to be investigated and I think you
know that that had a seven billion
dollar Equity value on Friday and got
received on a Sunday but that tells you
something right there when the FDIC
takes over Banks they take over banks at
5 pm on a Friday typically and then by
Monday morning first thing a new bank
has taken over the deposits but the the
Takeover of signature according to press
reports didn't happen until Sunday
afternoon
so that tells you something odd happened
right there it was also the New York
Department of Financial Services that
put them into receivership there is a
real question whether a solvent Bank can
be put into receivership there have been
people who have pointed out correctly
that that it is in the regulation that a
bank can be received for what what they
what they point it to which is that they
didn't get appropriate information and
why DFS didn't get appropriate
information from the management team
that is a fact that is a question of
fact did they did the management team
give the appropriate information to the
regulator we don't know the answer to
that but there's also a question of law
is that constitutional just because it's
on the books doesn't mean it's
constitutional it very well could be and
I think will be challenged because that
is a taking of private property if there
was positive Equity value now the next
thing I pointed out in a tweet yesterday
or the day before is if they had waited
one day not even one day you know 12
hours right because that's thing got
taken over on a Sunday afternoon the
fed's new new facility was put into
place there were plenty of Securities on
signatures books they would have been
liquid and would have probably I don't
know if no I don't know for sure but
pretty good chance that they would have
survived had they been allowed to open
the next day which is exactly what
Barney Frank had said they were solvent
and they were liquid and the and I'm
adding that they would have had access
to this new btfp
um fed facility so the interesting thing
is these three Federal Banking agencies
have been doing a lot of acting in
concert in the last couple of months but
historically they have not gotten along
and the FDIC Insurance Fund took a two
and a half billion dollar hit on
signature by the way they didn't sell
the deposits for the crypto industry if
they had how much of the two and a half
billion dollar hit would have been
recoverable that is something that that
will be investigated into because why
did the FDIC insurance one ticket two
and a half billion dollar hit on a bank
that might have actually been solvent
and the next day would have had
liquidity from the FED okay so that
there was something unusual that
happened there now what are the remedies
a Judicial right the shareholders some
of the shareholders have said they're
going to sue I don't think they have yet
B Congressional investigations but
American Banker reported that the fdic's
inspector General
um always reviews every single
receivership of of a bank that fund
which is only 128 billion dollars took a
two and a half billion dollar hit on a
bank that might have actually been
solvent okay watch that Inspector
General report it might take a year but
it also Elizabeth Warren just sent a
letter to the three inspectors general
of the three Federal Banking agencies
asking them for preliminary reports
within 30 days I think there is a
scandal there and I think um and and I
and I think the Inspector General who's
kind of like an internal auditor
um absolutely has the power there law
enforcement agents they are deputized uh
they they have subpoena power they
actually have arrest power as well they
have the power to get to the bottom if
something untoward happened
um and then the other the other piece is
of course the GAO which is the external
auditor okay so what are the remedies
it's the judicial system it's
Congressional investigations it's the
internal Auditors which which are the
inspectors general of the agencies and
it's the GAO which is which is the X
external auditor I think all four of
those are going to be looking into what
happened here and I do believe that it
all will come out eventually
as we watched choke point 2.0 continue
to kind of get executed
um one of the things people are looking
forward to uh and saying hey is the
timing interesting because fed now is
this new system that the FED is going to
put out this summer
um is it a cbdc is it something else are
you concerned with it how do you look at
fed now okay so fednow is a 24 7 365
real-time payment system and it they're
right there there is some allegation
that part of the reason the FED has gone
after custodia and stablecoin issuers
together and again custodia was going to
issue a digital dollar as a bank called
Abbott okay we have the patent granted
to us in July for a tokenized U.S dollar
deposit tokenized at a bank okay there
is some sense that by going after all
the stablecoin issuers that they are
clearing the runway for fed now and that
they viewed stable coins as a competitor
or to Fed now that now is not a cbdc I
actually don't agree with Biology that
that is a cbdc however his the the what
he's really getting at is that there's
going to be government surveillance of
our payments because
um the FED now obviously is a 24 7 365
real-time payment system that the FED is
running however it's still going to be
done through a bank so you do have a
third party not not a direct account at
the at the at the Federal Reserve you're
you're fed now is something you access
through your bank
not my by you banking directly at the
FED now all that said a lot of folks
think that there are privacy rights in
financial transactions right now the
fact is that if the government asks the
bank for all of your financial
transactions the banks have to comply
and they will because of the way the
bank regulatory regime works right
you're either compliant or you're not
um and so there's really not much
Financial privacy I hate to reveal it to
folks there's not much Financial privacy
right now there is that layer of your
bank between you and the government but
it's a it's a it's a it's a thin layer
with a pretty
um transparent uh you know layer in
between
um so so this whole concept of of
surveilling our financial transactions
and basically debanking us is is already
real and it is what we're talking about
operation choke point
um if you I know a lot of individuals
who have lost access to bank accounts
for have having
um you know transacted with coinbase
because the banks just don't want to
deal with anyone who's touching crypto
they're so afraid of The Regulators
coming after them and they have reason
to believe they have reason to be that
afraid because The Regulators behind the
scenes have done some pretty crazy stuff
and I hope all that comes out Bankers
have been telling me that people I have
never met have contacted me to tell me
about what their banks are going through
from the pressure that they've been
getting from Bank regulators and it's
really crazy stuff
before we talk about Bitcoin and kind of
where you think that's going
um I wanted you to flip around the table
and make the argument as to what is the
Fed done well what is the argument for
why you think the US dollar could Remain
the global Reserve currency and kind of
not be debased away like how do you
think about maybe the uh the pro
argument for uh the other side right and
really kind of the fed's actions and a
lot of uh kind of the dollar Bulls if
you will
well I'll give you one thing the FED has
done really well they've taken back the
power from the the non-us banks and the
euro dollar market
by changing to sulfur the secured
overnight funding rate from Libor
there's an analyst Tom loongo who's done
some really good work on this had tip to
him
um and and a lot of others have been
watching the transition away from Libor
Libor the London interbank offered rate
is basically when I said in the 1950s
that this euro dollar market got created
because the Russians needed a place to
put their US Dollars and the British
Bank stepped up when the U.S banks in
the 1950s during the Cold War would not
um the basically the the London banks
have controlled the Libor rate now
here's the issue in the 2008 financial
crisis this is a london-based interest
rate that the FED had no control over
okay and and it's the floating rate
interest rate that on which trillions of
dollars of US dollar debt that is priced
and the FED has no control over it the
FED stepped up and took control of the
floating interest rate back by forcing a
change to the secured overnight funding
rate which is a control a rate that the
FED itself controls okay so that is
basically the FED stepping up against
the sort of the Davos crowd if you will
the international the global crowd that
is controlled out of Europe and through
the control of Libor Europe had control
over the Fed
and that caused real problems in the
2008 financial crisis the FED has been
making aggressive moves to take that
control back for itself because the U.S
is the global Reserve currency there
have been
um there's there's a I can't remember
who said it but the dollar is our
currency and it's your problem
um basically that's what that's what
Powell is moving back towards that that
they don't want the non-us interests to
control monetary policy they want U.S
interest to control monetary policy we
want to go back to that
um I can't remember who said that it's
it that the dollar is our currency but
it's your problem
um we that's what that's exactly what
what Powell is trying to do and that is
one thing the FED has done well the rest
of it they have been in in D in reactive
mode and again it is so fascinating to
me that you see both political parties
you see bipartisan efforts to to to get
transparency see into the FED to get
um you know there was just a bill
introduced by both the Democrat and
Republican yesterday to to change the
fed's governance structure so that
Congress has more authority over it this
is I I put out a tweet asking if if any
other fed Watchers have seen this much
pressure on the FED as an institution
and having it on the run and playing
defense as much as it is today and
nobody else stepped forward and said
that they knew of any other time when
the Fed was under this much pressure as
an institution
when we look at the current situation it
seems nearly impossible for them to
solve there's a brand new article that's
out in Tablet Mag uh by
um uh rinsberg and what he talks about
is you know this has Echoes of 2008
financial crisis it's the response to
that but it could be way worse there's
kind of not a svb you know kind of tech
bro Venture Capital problem this is a
global debt crisis that we're seeing
here and we've got to be able to to fix
it
there are a lot of people including you
and myself who believe that Bitcoin is a
potential solution to the problem right
some people believe that it is the only
solution some people believe it is one
of many solutions
talk a little bit as to how you see
Bitcoin in the current system in terms
of like the short term and then how does
what's happening right now change or
kind of reiterate your view over the
long term as well
well uh you know right now the folks in
control in the US are trying to shove it
all up sure uh and they've done a lot of
damage to the U.S industry but again the
price of Bitcoin going up in their face
tells the tells tells us that they don't
have any power to uh to to shut down
Bitcoin which they don't it's just code
anyone with a phone can run the code
right
um and and I would underscore anyone
with a phone including the eight billion
people in the world
can actually create and transact in US
dollars right now if they download the
lightning Network open source code right
so the bank Regulators are absolutely
going to lose control over this and the
sad thing to answer your question is
they don't understand that there are
more they're more afraid of it and
trying to shove us back into Old
technology and to the analog world then
recognizing okay the world has changed
and we're going to have to update the
way we think about it and I lament this
pump because
I've spent just the last two and a half
years of my life trying to work with
them and when I saw that Brian
Armstrong's tweet storm about it they
had 30 meetings with the SEC just in the
last six months or something like that
and these were one-way meetings and they
and and coinbase was actively trying to
help find an answer to the question what
is a security within the digital asset
space that's not my fight coinbase has
obviously been taking that fight what I
the what I've been working on is how do
you get the bank regulatory regime to
recognize that the world has changed and
there is a safe and sound way to plug
these two technologies together in a way
that they don't hurt each other I don't
want the traditional Financial system to
be hurt by by the digital assets uh or
especially Bitcoin and I don't want
Bitcoin to be hurt by the traditional
Financial system and to be honest the
traditional Financial system has really
hurt Bitcoin
um it's not the other way around but
these two are going to coexist and the
sad thing is by shoving it all offshore
they're going to be playing whack-a-mole
and and frankly they're going to be
exposures that are going to show up
probably through correspondent banks
that they didn't even know existed
because they're trying to shove it
offshore and not really understand it
and what I like to point to is that
January 3rd interagency statement that
kicked off the whole operation 2.2.0 in
retrospect
it had something absolutely hilarious in
it it discouraged the banks from using
open public and or decentralized
protocols
TCP is an open public and or
decentralized protocol
SMTP voice over Internet Protocol okay
these open source internet protocols
that make up the internet that we all
use every day are open public and our
decentralized protocols and the and the
bank Regulators just told the banks they
don't want them using open public and or
decentralized protocols
not in the context of that White House
report that questioned the value of
financial Innovation the bank Regulators
are trying hard
to stop the banks from from adopting new
technologies folks it's there in black
and white right there and at first when
that came out I laughed and said well
this is what happens when lawyers write
who aren't familiar with how technology
works you know our writing policy and
then it's not put out for public
comments so that they can't be told hey
you massively overreached here you
effectively just banned the internet
maybe that boy's what they meant to do
all along right because look at what
they just did they went after the banks
that were using the most tech forward
um infrastructures in their in their
banking stacks and so I you know I don't
know where we're gonna have to see how
this all plays out but this anti-tech
crowd is very real and they're in
control right now I I find it
fascinating from a political perspective
because we got an election coming up in
in you know in November basically 18
months away we got a presidential
election is that really what the Biden
Administration wants to be seen as
anti-tech and and as regressive in
financial technology trying to push us
back into an analog world especially
given the the demographics of who uses
digital assets I'm really floored
because they everybody's going after the
the 20 and 30 something voters and if
those 20 and 30 something voters are
being you know told they can't use
something that they've been comfortable
using for a while so
uh you know how are they going to react
it's just an interesting political
question and I'm asking it rhetorically
because I keep thinking that the cooler
heads in the Biden Administration are
going to Prevail and um reverse some of
this let's hope
my last question before I let you go
um Bitcoin as a solution to the problem
the FED obviously has high degree of
confidence that they can solve the
current problem but there's always a
tail risk that they can't are we now at
a point where the public conversation
needs to turn that the Federal Reserve
would benefit from putting some Bitcoin
on their balance sheet as a way to
create Insurance in case they can't
actually quell whether it's this crisis
or the next one
yeah look I'm not going to advocate for
that but what I would advocate for is
people who really do know what they're
doing in the digital asset industry
being within their fold okay that was us
that was custodia spending a lot of time
helping to educate and there are a lot I
I I'm hoping that a lot of what we did
ultimately gets made public through the
production of the administrative record
which which will be coming um down the
down the pike uh in in our pending
lawsuit to the extent that
um that that uh well I I can't talk
about what's next but just watch because
a lot of what custodia did to help
educate the FED boy it would be
eye-opening
um because then when you realize how the
fed you know treated us in a in a
vicious way uh it's it's it's it's boy
is it going to reflect poorly on them I
think because we were a friendly and we
were trying hard to help them figure out
the challenge that they face it is a
challenge
but it's also not going away it's like
the taxi and limousine commissions with
Uber how do you deal with the fact that
the technology industry is just going
around you
okay if you want to stay relevant and
you and you want to deliver what people
are voting with their feet to use which
is the better technology
then you need to figure out a way to
bring it inside the regulatory
umbrella instead of shoving out the
people who were actually actively trying
to help you that is my message to all
the regulators and they they are they
absolutely did the opposite they as
coinbase said you know those who came in
and tried to help and try to educate and
tried to get under the regulatory
regime were the ones who got skewered
the hardest
it is uh incredible to kind of think how
all of this is happening at once and I
wrote it last week but I still keep
going back to the uh the Lenin quote
which is just you know there are decades
where nothing happens and there are
literally weeks where decades happen and
it feels like we're in one of those
times right now uh Caitlyn thank you so
much for taking the time to do this I
always learned so much when I talk to
you where can we send people to find you
on the internet or find out more about
custodia yeah okay Caitlyn long
underscore custodiabank.com and I would
also say for those of you who are new
and are listening to this from tradfy uh
go look at Jameson lops um uh Twitter
account because he's got he's a Bitcoin
core developer and he's got a lot of of
the basically how to get started in
Bitcoin it is a daunting thing
especially for people who have lived in
the traditional World your whole lives
the whole idea of how do I buy it and
then how do I self-custody it
um and how do I self-custody in a way
that if I if if we are really getting to
the point where the off ramps are being
being closed down
frankly you can memorize what's called
your seed recovery phrase in Bitcoin and
walk across a border with it okay
there's and there's there's no proof
that anybody could could make you prove
that you had Bitcoin right if you don't
have it physically written down anywhere
you don't have it on a device okay start
thinking about start playing forward
those ugly scenarios in which you want
to try to protect your own wealth
against authoritarian governments be
they from the right or the left in any
country in the world you can memorize
your seed phrase and walk across a
border to a place that's free and uh and
then download your Bitcoin next time you
get an internet connection and that this
is pretty powerful stuff this is this is
the reason why ultimately the bank
regulators and the politicians who are
trying to regress the United States in
financial technology are just wrong and
they're not going to win and that's I
again I very much hope cooler heads will
prevail thank you Satoshi whoever you
are for creating Bitcoin it was created
for exactly this environment and uh good
luck everybody on your orange pill
Journey
there's no better way to end this
conversation than that Caitlyn thank you
so much we'll do it again in the future
awesome thank you